Michael when we first contacted you to
do the interview for the Six stage plot
structure we thought it'd be fun for you
to break down a script applying your
structure you obliged we were very happy
to hear that you chose a few good men
from 1992 curious why you chose the
movie not nothing against it but no
that's good I hope you're not miserable
now a whole discussion a number of
reasons the first and foremost is just
one of my all-time favorite movies and I
don't really enjoy discussing movies
that I don't love I don't really like
using bad examples and so on I think
it's just one of the great American
screenplays and movies certainly the
best courtroom drama soon you know 12
Angry Men and I'd have a hard time
equivocating between those two also
because it was written it's based on a
play written by Aaron Sorkin he wrote
the script and went on to become huge as
a both a screenwriter and the television
writer because this was all predated
sports night in West Wing and so on so
he's now one of the best-known
screenwriters in Hollywood so I thought
that would be interesting to look at it
that way but also the main purpose is to
kind of clarify and make simpler my
particular approach to story structure
and character arc and because this
follows that pattern or that formula or
whatever you want to call it so clearly
and in such a straightforward way I
thought I think it's a great example
because it's very easy to see as you
pick the movie apart where all the
elements that I talked about in
structuring character are there so I
just thought this would be a good fun
one to talk about okay excellent well
let's get started
so we'll take what the set up which is
stage one we're going to Act one you
want to start sure talking about let me
let me give a little backdrop here so
for those of you who haven't seen the
other interview we did going into depth
about my approach to the 6/8 structure
and character arc I'll review some of
that so you'll be caught up and you'll
understand what I'm talking about in my
approach to structure or plot structure
I find that successful movies are always
divided into six basic stages and those
stages are created by five key turning
points in the script or in the movie and
even more to the point or even neater
those turning points always occur at
essentially the same place in every
movie so whatever happens at the ten
percent point of Titanic is going to
happen at the ten percent point of
Zootopia and it's going to happen at the
ten percent point of a few good men so
these are things that I think it
behooves screen writers and filmmakers
to model because if this is work
consistently in so many successful
movies you probably want to replicate
this approach in your own writing and in
terms of character arc I'm going to get
into that and explain that as we go
through and I start talking about how
these characters are revealed and how we
go deeper into the characters what their
inner journey and there are car and so
on like that so we'll get to that part
as far as the six stages are concerned
the first stage is as you say what I
call this setup it's the first 10% of
the movie or of the screenplay and as a
screenwriter or filmmaker there are a
few key things you need to do in that
stretch first thing you must do is
introduce the hero of the movie hero is
just my term for the protagonist the
main character it's the one we're
rooting for the character we empathize
with or identify with it's the
characters desire defines the plot of
the story is and whose desire drives it
forward a hero just to clarify is not
someone who is heroic unless maybe
you're talking about a superhero in a
movie but even then at the beginning not
so much probably currently what I call a
hero is more a character who has the
potential to become heroic and in the
movie especially if there's a movie with
a character arc where the hero has to
and a certain degree of emotional
courage that's part of what the story is
about is how do they find their own
heroism how do they move into the truth
of who they are so in the setup of a few
good men we begin with something I call
an outside action opening most of the
time in screenplays the hero is the
first character on the page and when you
submit your script to be read the
assumption of the reader will usually be
whoever's name appears first that's the
hero of the story but you can oftentimes
seduce that you're seduced the reader or
the audience into the story or easily if
you begin with a moment of great
conflict so the movie will begin with
something that does not involve the hero
you'll see this in da Vinci Code where
it starts with a murder there or a
number of other thrillers and so on so
in a few good man it opens that get more
wanton MO they base and we see a soldier
getting we're not quite aware of it at
the time but we see a soldier getting
smothered and find out he is dead he
will die then we cut to the another
character in the movie so we're still
delaying the revelation of the hero the
effect of that while it's a little
dangerous sometimes to have the reader
keep wondering well Who am I rooting for
here it does create more and more
anticipation okay well who's going to
who's going to be leading this parade
here where is the hero so we're
introduced to um Joanne Galloway there'd
be more character I'll talk more about
how she functions in the story when we
meet her and we find out there's been
this death the Navy wants her as an
internal affairs attorney to look into
it they wanted to sort of supervise she
hopes they'll let her be the attorney
but she's not they're going to assign
her another attorney so all of that is
set up and we're wondering well who is
going to be assigned to this and since
the audience already knows the stars Tom
Cruise they probably have figured out
it's going to be him
and then we cut to the hero notice all
of this is still in this first 10% so
about five pages or five minutes and
then it cuts to the Tom Cruise character
Daniel Kaffee I'm looking down at notes
because I'm not always good at
remembering character names but we meet
him and what do we meet when we first
see him he's out hitting a baseball or a
softball - one of the other you know
sailors or whatever and another attorney
comes up and he's not shown up at a
meeting Kaffee hasn't and the guy wants
to plea-bargain a deal and he wants to
demand five years in prison and so on
and we see Kathy plea bargain that down
- no jail time just a misdemeanor and so
on because he says the guy just had a
bag of oregano he didn't even know it
was he just thought it was marijuana and
so on so what does this show us and he
finally wins so it shows us a few things
first of all because we feel sort of
sorry for this guy who had the bag of
oregano we start to like Kathy
immediately because he's on the side of
this this other guy he's a likable guy
and he seems well-liked by the guy he's
playing catch with or hitting the ball
to and so on so being likable is one key
way to establish empathy with a hero and
that's one of the main things you have
to do as soon as you introduce the hero
another thing we find out he's highly
skilled so we admire the character he
may be kind of slick and quick about how
he does it but it's kind of amazing how
he's able to get what was going to be
five years in the brig down to no jail
time and a misdemeanor and just just
something on his record that's going to
be meaningless in other words he gets
the guy off so we're very admiring of
that about him and the way he does it is
very funny and were drawn to characters
who make us laugh oftentimes because
they also have the courage to say things
we wouldn't have the courage to say
they're not real politically correct and
he's very sarcastic and puts people down
and so on so all of this is to introduce
this to this character and create
empathy with this hero and then we come
to the 10% point of the movie
you